Cet été.
La série événement arrive sur Golden Moustache.
Un trône.
Des familles prêtes à tout pour se le procurer.
Je parle bien évidemment de la série...
Ah non, non mais je parlais pas de ça.
Oui je connais la série à laquelle vous pensez là euh...
Elle est un petit peu surcotée à mon gout.
Mais oui, oui, je vois très bien.
Je vois très bien.
Je dis pas que j'aime pas hein.
Mais voilà quoi.
Bref. Je parle de la série...
Le Trône des Frogz !
Le trône de fer ?
Bah moi j'ai envie de vous dire : pourquoi pas.
On est une des maisons les plus anciennes du Royaume.
Notre maître d'arme, c'est un descendant des chevaucheurs de dragons...
Du continent disparu.
Allumez !
Fort de notre grande expérience...
Nous pensons que nous sommes les dignes héritiers du trône de fer.
Sur papier c'est...
C'est mon château quoi.
Nous sommes les Frogz.
Etre une femme lettrée entourée de sauvages sans éducation...
C'est pas le plus dur.
Putain c'est des cailloux, chope le !
Le vrai problème c'est plus les tentatives de viols pendant les repas.
J'ai tout de suite senti que j'étais pas chaud.
Mon épouse, elle est où ?
C'est Clarisse.
Tu nous dis comment vaincre tes frères...
Et nous t'offrons une bougie parfumée.
J'ai trouvé que ça.
L'hiver arrive.
Est-ce qu'on pourrait pas décaler l'hiver ?
Ils ont trouvé une solution pour vaincre les marcheurs blancs.
Après pour moi ça reste des clodos.
Alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que, pour les tuer...
Faut les planter avec ça.
La mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'on a aucune idée de ce que c'est.
J'me casse.